今天想给大家推荐一惠州这边的一个带孩子去玩儿的一个地方，
我觉得挺好的，
叫半岛公园，
我不知道惠州这边朋友有没有人去过的，
半岛公园里面他有吃的，
有喝的，
有玩儿的，
可以带着孩子去转一转，
有的时候还有露天唱歌的呢，
露天KTV也可以。
我为啥给大家推荐这个半岛公园呢？
因为我昨天跟月儿嫂跟小姑子，
我们三个人带着孩子去那个半岛公园，
发现了一个好玩的事儿，
昨天买了几个小家伙事儿给你看一下啊，
看到那个姐姐在用那个钩针勾出来的，
是不是挺真的，
就是勾出来这个形状啊，
看这个小向日葵啊，
你猜一下多少钱？
诶，
你看这个小紫葫芦，
我买了一个死葫芦给我自己是一个好的寓意啊，
你猜一下多少钱？
哎，
这个小马儿马上还背着钱呢，
马上有钱，
我也感觉挺好的，
人家这个手艺是潮汕非遗毛线勾织，
我为啥要给他推荐这个暗岛公园，
是因为我觉得我的姐妹当中可能有很多人郁闷，
心情不好，
心里很郁结。
我感觉你去了解一下这个钩针啊，
学一下这个手艺啊，
能对你有帮助，
因为一个人如果沉浸在他勾的这些艺术品的时候，
他会进入一种心流。
状态，
这种心流状态会覆盖掉你的一些心中的愤懑，
或者说能化解掉心中的一些结，
打开的结，
所以给大家做这个推荐。
那个姐姐我没有留人家联系方式，
她也不认识我，
而且我去的时候也乔装打扮过了，
就是跟我平时看着也不太一样，
所以你们去的时候不用提我。
如果你真的是喜欢这些小工艺品的话，
你可以去买一点，
不过也就10块、
15块，
20来块钱的样子，
如果你想跟人家学习的话，
你得尊重人家，
你得问人家愿不愿意交，
什么情况下才愿意交，
要不要给人家交点学费啊，
干嘛干嘛的啊，
我就纯属是因为想到我有很多姐妹，
因为她心里面有很多结，
解不开，
每天也不开心，
也不知道该干点啥，
如果你对这些东西感兴趣的话，
你可以去那个地方去买一点这些小工艺品，
你可以坐在那儿看人家勾勾一段时间了，
你看看你自己有没有这个兴趣，
想不想学啊，
网上也有很多的教程，
而且还是免费的。